ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะ
ๆ
อะไรคะ
หญิงนั่งเก้าอี้เหรอค่ะดีเก้าอี้ค่ะต้อง
ใจ
มีเก้าอี้มีเก้าอี้แล้ววันนี้มีเก้าอี้
แล้ว
ทุกวันไม่เห็นใช่มะปลาเนี่ยมองไม่เห็น
เก้าอี้วันนี้ครูเอ๋เห็นเก้าอี้ตกใจขา
เคยหญิงคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันเสาร์
ค่ะ
วันนี้วันเสาร์อ่าวันเท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 2
ค่ะวันที่ 2 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนเมษายน
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพตเท่าไหร่คะอีผช
2565 ค่ะปีคศต.ยคะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะ
2022 นะคะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลา
15:00 น
14 นาทีค่ะบ่าย 15:00 น 14 นาทีนะคะ
สาเหตุครูผู้หญิงคุยไก่คะ
ใช่ค่ะเอ๋อยากเล่นเกมโอ้โหได้ค่ะเล่นเกม
ผู้หญิงเดี๋ยวดูวันนี้นักเรียนของเรา
มากี่คนคะขอนักเรียนของเราเนี่ยมามา 1  2
3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10  10 คนค่ะของ
เรามา 10 คนนะคะเราอยากได้นักเรียนคนที่
11 เนาะงูนักเรียนคนที่ 11 คอมเม้นข้าง
ล่างนะคะที่ฉันคนที่ 11 นะคะ
สวัสดีค่ะค่ะคุณเค้าสวัสดีค่ะคุณชายราชิ
สวัสดีค่ะคุณ Black พิษผู้หญิงสวัสดีนัก
เรียนด้วยจำจำชื่อนักเรียนได้ไหมจำ
ก็ได้ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะคุณแรสใช่ไหมอ่ะพูด Bag
พี่พูดไปแล้วสวัสดีค่ะคุณโรเบิร์ตคุณ Cash
คุณประวีณา
คุณลิซ่าค่ะคุณแจฮี
คุณมาเรียนเจเจ 2 คนคุณ John เทคซ่าแล้ว
ก็ก็คุณ John สวีเดนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
10คนของเราเรานะคะ
โอเคนักเรียนวันนี้ครูเอ๋มีเกม
แต่คุณนักเรียนอาจจะ
ปวดหัวนิดหน่อยเอาอุ๊ยมีเกมให้นักเรียน
เกรด A มีเกมให้ครูหญิงมีเกมให้นักเรียน
คืนให้ใส่ผู้หญิงให้คุณหญิงเลือกตัวแทน
นักเรียน
ได้ค่ะนักเรียนน่ะข้ามทูตหูเปลี่ยนดูแล้ว
ก็ฟัง
งั้นเนี่ยนักเรียนก็คิดใช่ไหมคิดคิดเองสี
อะไรนะๆเอมของครูเอ๋เจอมีรูปนะคะเราก็มี
สีและปิดปิดปิดคะอ๋ออ๋อ
เราก็ให้นักเรียนเปิดแล้วก็คิดอะไรแค่ได้
ค่ะแต่ว่ากูเอกอยากมีเทคนิคหลายๆอย่าง
งั้นเทคนิคที่ซองคือมีรูปแล้วก็มีนิด
หน่อยนิดหน่อยให้ดูแล้วก็คิดอะไรออกครู
หญิงต้องเลือกเหรอคะ
ใช่เดี๋ยวกูอ่ะจะเปิดให้ดูครูหญิงจะเลือก
อะไรอ่อได้ค่ะนะคะผู้หญิงเรื่องแล้วนัก
เรียนช่วยครูหญิงเอาสีอะไรนะคะได้ค่ะนะฮะ
กูเอ็มเปิดนะคะ
เพื่อนๆ
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเห็นไหมคะยังค่ะ
ถามใช่ไหมคะสาวใสๆของครูเอ๋เอ๋กำลัง Share
screen
เห็นแล้วค่ะแล้วเสียงจะปิดอันอื่นก่อนทำ
ตัวใหญ่ก่อน
ไปไหน
เดี๋ยวนะคะผู้หญิงใจเย็นๆใจเย็นๆใจเย็นๆ
เห็นไหมเห็นค่ะเห็นแล้ว
ผู้หญิงกูอะมีรูปนะมีเกมนี้จะมีทั้งหมด
อีก 1  2  3  4 รูปนะคะมีมีรูปที่ 1 น่ะ
เป็นมีสีแล้วก็ปิดปิดปิดนะคะรูปที่รูปที่
3 ก็มีสีแล้วก็ปิดปิดปิด
รูปที่ 2 เนี่ยเห็นนิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยนิด
หน่อย
รูปที่ 4 ก็เห็นนิดหน่อยนิดหน่อยอ่าเออ
ครูหญิงเข้าใจแล้วที่ครูเอ๋พูดออกปวดหัว
กลัวเอ๋
ทำอะไรออกกูเอง 2 อย่างเอกก็ได้โอเค
ผู้หญิงจะเอาเห็นนิดหน่อยหรือเอาเปิดก่อน
คะเอาเปิดก่อนอ๋อเคเคเปิดก่อนนะคะครูหญิง
อ่ารูปนี้นะคะอุ้ยรูปนี้
รูปนี้เนี่ยจะมีสีสีนะคะสี
อ่ะ
โอเคใส่ Number ให้ก็ได้นะคะถ้ามีกี่สี
แหละคะครูเอ๋มีหนึ่งมาไหม
นะครับมินทร์ 1
3  4  5  6
6  7
8  9
น่าจะ 9 นะค่ะนะ 9
นะ 90 สีนะคะคุยอิงอาผู้หญิงต้องทำอะไรคะ
ธพี่เก๋สิรูปนี้เนี่ยไม่รู้อะไรอ่ะผู้
หญิงจะเปิดหรือคิดเลยอร่อย
คิดเลยไม่ได้ผู้หญิงอะไรไม่เข้าใจ
ไม่เข้าใจใช่ไหมงั้นครูหญิงต้องเลือกสี
แล้วครูเอ๋จะเปิดให้อ่ะสีอะไรก็ได้ใช่ไหม
มี 9 สีก็ผู้หญิงกับถ้าเลือก 111 สีแล้ว
เปิดแล้วต้องก็จะได้ 9 คะแนน
แล้วถ้าผู้หญิงดูแล้วตอบเลยตอนนี้ได้ 10
คริหญิงไม่เข้าใจค่ะ
ผู้หญิงไม่เอาสิไม่เอา 10 คะแนนค่ะครู
หญิงอยากเปิดอยากมีสี on นักเรียนก็บอก
อยากเปิดใช่แล้วเปิดสีโอเคผู้หญิงเปิดสี
ไหนก่อนคะ
ผู้หญิงอยากเปิดสีม่วงค่ะเบอร์ 5
อยากเปิดสีเหลืองสิ่งจะเปิดสีเดียวใช่ไหม
หวยอ่ะ
ก็สีม่วงเบอร์ 5 เนี่ยใหญ่
ก็เลยอยากเปิดเบอร์ 5 ค่ะสีม่วงผู้หญิง
มั้ยเปลี่ยนใจใช่ไหมคะ
ครูเอ๋คะครูหญิงเปิดทั้งหมดก็โอเคใช่ไหม
โอเคไม่ค่ะใบ้เกมผู้หญิงเปลี่ยนใจก็ได้
แปลว่าสีม่วงไม่โอเค
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงเปิดสีม่วงกูเอ๋ตายเลยอ่ะ
ไม่รู้หญิงเปิดเอ่อเปิดเบอร์ 7 สีแดงค่ะ
สีแดงโอเคสีแดงโอเค
คู๋ซิกแซกนะคะสีแดงสีแดงสี
แดงได้ไม่อาจได้แล้วโอเคเปิดสีแดง
สีฟ้าด้วย
x ป๋าดูเอก
เดินสีแดงไม่เห็นอะไรเลยเห็นแล้วกูหญิง
เดี๋ยวนะอันนี้สีแดง
ไม่ไม่เข้าใจให้ไงเนี่ยอ้ะสีแดง
เบอร์ n สี
คิดเห็นหน่อยไหมเข้าใจ
นิดหน่อยไหมเข้าใจ
กริ๊งเปิดได้อีกใช่ไหมคะครูเอ๋หมดค่ะสี
อะไรก็ได้ผู้หญิงเปิดสีดำเปิดสีดำใช่ไหม
คะอ่าดำสีดำเบอร์ 1 ไปนะคะเทป 1 เปิดนะ
อะไรอะไรอะไรอะไร
ผู้หญิงเห็นผู้หญิงเห็นต้นเสาค่ะทนเสาร์ 5
ผู้หญิงเห็นยังเห็นอะไรเห็นต้นเสาต้นเสา
ใช่ไหมคะ
ถ้าเนี่ยต้นเสาแล้วก็
ไม่รู้อะไรอันนี้ไม่รู้อะไรใช่ไหมคะเฮ้ย
เฮ้ยผู้หญิงเปิดอีกค่ะยกเว้นสีม่วง
รู้หญิงเปิด
สีฟ้าเปิดสีฟ้าผู้หญิงก็รู้เหมือนกันผู้
หญิง
สีฟ้าสีฟ้าอ่ะอันนี้ก่อน
สีฟ้าสีฟ้า
ฟิล์มเปิดสีขาวคู๋เปิดสีขาวใช่ไหมคะ
ขอบคุณขาวค่ะ
สีขาวผู้หญิงปานะ
ใครอะไร
อะไรครับผู้หญิง
อะไรล่ะเวลาดู
ดูเนี่ยคุณก็ไม่มีสีเทา
สีเทาเทาๆสีเทา
อากูเอคุยทำให้สีเทา
สักครู่นะคะค่ะมีสีเทาไหมโอเค
สีเทาสีเทา
ไม่เท่านั้นชมพู
เก๋มีสีเทาที่ครูหญิงเห็นก็ไม่ใช่สีเทา
ของไม่เข้าใจสักครูเอ๋ผู้หญิงเปิดได้ค่ะ
เปิดได้อีกอันนี้กูเองไม่ห้ามแล้วผู้หญิง
เปิดสีเหลืองเบอร์ 4 สีเหลืองนะคะโอเค
f อ่ะ
โอเคสีเหลืองนะคะช่าคะผู้หญิงเปิดเปิด
เบิร์ด 4  5
อย่าทิ้งรู้หรือยังอะไรดีเอ็นเหมือนสาว 1
2  3 แล้วก็มีโซ่ตรงนี้ค่ะไม่คิด
ผู้หญิงไม่แน่ใจขอเปิดอีกหนึ่ง
เปิดสีอะไรคะสีฟ้ามั้ยคะเปิดสีเขียวแก่
ค่ะเบอร์ 8 เบอร์ 8 สีเขียวแก่ครู f เปิด
นะถ้าเปิดแล้วนะได้ค่ะ
กดนะกดกด
เบอร์ 8
อะไร
โง่ครูหญิงคิดว่ารู้แล้วเปิดอีกหน่อยอีก
ลิงค์เปิด
มีแต่ไม่แน่ใจอยากชวน
100% ผู้หญิงเปิดสีฟ้าค่ะเบอร์ 6 สีฟ้า
เบอร์ 6 เจริญเจอการเปิดนะคะเปิดค่ะเปิด
[เพลง]
อะไรคะผู้หญิงรู้แล้วค่ะครูเอ๋
อะไรคะผู้หญิง
ช้างค่ะแล้วล้างหน้าฉานใช่ไหมคะใช้เอกค่ะ
เดี๋ยวนะเหลือ 1  2  3 ผู้หญิงได้เท่า
ไหร่ค่ะ 3 คะแนน
3 คะแนน 3 คะแนน
คู๋ผู้หญิงเปิด 6 เหลือ 3 สิ่งได้ 3
คะแนนจริงๆคือเอกซิกแซกใช่มั้ยนักเรียน
ไหนเปิดสีม่วงได้ไหมสีม่วงจะเปิดปุ๊บรู้
เลย
สีม่วงเป็นอะไรคะผู้หญิงเป็นงวงช้างค่ะสี
ม่วงนะคะตรงนี้
โอเคเอดส์ต้องนี้เนี่ยงวงช้างช้างครูหญิง
เห็นง่วงครูหญิงรู้รูปช้าง
ถ้าเป็นสีม่วงเปิดใช่ไหมคะผู้หญิง
9 คะแนนแหละจ่ายกูไอ้ใต้เลย
สีม่วงปิดก็วันใหญ่
ก็เป็นงวงช้างนะคะจะยาวนะคนเนี่ยจมูกแต่
ว่าช้างเนี่ยยาวก็ไม่พูดว่าจมูกพูดว่า
อะไรนะคะง่วงค่ะงัวนะฮะกูช้ายแบบช้างตัว
นี้ไม่มีอันนี้เนาะไม่มีอะไรคะไม่มีงาน
r&d มีไม่มีงานะคะช้างตัวนี้เป็นช้างสี
ชมพูนะผู้หญิงดูชม
สีชมพูเราเรียกว่าอะไรคะช้างสีชมพูเนี่ย
ช้างเผือกหรอคะครูเอ๋ช้างเผือกกูเปิด
เบอร์ 9 ออกนะคะ
ด้วยเกล้าเบอร์ 3 พรรคหนู
ไม่เข้าใจไม่เข้าใจค่ะเปิดเบอร์ 9 อาจจะ
นิดหน่อยระเบิด 9 นี้สีสีอะไรคะสีส้มสี
ส้มบริษามสีอะไรคะสีเขียวอ่อนค่ะเดี๋ยว
อ่อนอ่ะก็เปิดฟรีส้มเปิดสีเขียวอ่อนนะคะ
ก็หมอช้างไปแล้วออกเบอร์ 1 ใช่ไหมสีดำผู้
หญิงเห็นหางช้างนี่เองที่หญิงตอนแรกไม่
เข้าใจหน้าอันนี้หางช้าง
อาหลังช้างแต่ก็มีหูช้างท้องช้าง
ขาช้างค่ะแล้วก็หูช้าง
กลัวช้า
อันแรกอ่ะอันที่กูหญิงเลือก
งวงช้างค่ะ
โอเค
ครูเอ๋ชนะใช่ไหมใส่ค่ะ
ต่อไป
อันที่ 2 ไม่ใช่เปิดละ
ครูเปิดให้ผู้หญิงดูเลยค่ะค่ะอ่ะฮะโอเค
ผู้หญิงจะเห็นนิ้วนิ้วนะนิ้วแล้วก็มีเล็บ
นะคะผู้หญิงคิดว่ารูปเนื้ออะไร
เงี้ยอือ
ไม่ใช่โฟกัสมือจับมือเอามาทำแบบนี้
มีมืออยู่แบบนี้
โทษหรอ
ไม่ใช่
อันนี้คือถ้าคุณหญิงตอบได้นะให้ 10 คะแนน
เลย
คนนี้ได้มั้ยนิ้วๆอะไรนิ้วเอานิ้วมาโชว์
นี้วันเนี้ยเท่านิ้ว
ผู้หญิงไม่รู้มีให้ดูอีกไหมเป้รูปที่ 2
คุยให้ดูมีนิ้วแล้วก็มีอะไรไม่รู้มี 2
นักเรียนม
มี
อะไรอะไรไม่รู้รู้ 2 รูปก็ยังไม่เข้าใจมี
รูปที่ 3 ให้ดูไหมคะผู้หญิงกำลังโกรธเหรอ
คะ
พี่สาวเข้าใจไหม
อันป่าเดี๋ยวนะแป๊บนึงนะคะ
อันนี้เนี่ยรูปที่ 1 นิ้วเข้าใจรูปที่ 2
อะไหล่
สาว
ตัว a  v  Z แค่นี้มีสารรู้
มี 3 รูปผู้หญิงเราจะอะหินเอานิ้ว
เนี่ยไปเทียบกับอะไร
ผู้หญิงดูดีๆเดี๋ยวกูเอกขยายไหมอุ้ยเพลง
ค่ะแล้วผู้หญิงเคลียร์ตัวเอง
อ่ะขยายให้ผู้หญิงเห็นไหมมีนิ้ว
แล้วก็พูดอะไรไม่รู้อะไรอ่ะเอานิ้ว
5 อะไรผู้หญิงผู้หญิงมีหนึ่งใช่ไหมคะมี
1  2  3 เป็นรูปเดียวกันผู้หญิงเกมดูดีๆ
ดูอันนี้ 3 ดีๆอันที่สามเนี่ยอะไร
สีสีอะไรคะอันที่ 3 สีสีทองค่ะ
สีเหลืองสีเหลืองสีเหลืองเหรอคะสีเหลือง
นอนสีเหลืองเนี่ยสีเหลืองสีเหลืองสี
เหลืองสีเหลืองอะไรสีเหลืองคุยถึง
คุณเรียนเหรอเอา
ไว้ใช้ทุเรียนโอเคกินได้กินได้ยินได้กิน
ได้
กินได้เป็นอาหาร
ไม่ใช่อาหารอาหารไว้เป็นเป็นผลไม้
[เพลง]
กล้วย
กล้วยอะไร
กล้วยหอมเหรอกล้วยหอมมีนิ้วมินิวส์กล้วย
อะไรกล้วย
กล้วยอะไร
พูดอะไรก็หญิง
ผู้หญิงไม่เข้าใจ
อะไรอ่ะกล้วยปิ้งไม่ใช่
ไม่ใช่ถ้าวิ่งโอเคกล้วยโอเคโอเคโอเค
เดี๋ยวนะเดี๋ยวกูเอาเฉลยนะคะเวรซะเลยค่ะ
เฉลยนะผู้หญิงเห็นไว้น่ะเห็นกล้วยหักมุก
เหรอตัวเองฉันจะได้แป้น
ตั้งแต่ๆกล้วยอะไรกล้วยเล็บมือนาง
ไปแล้ว
ทองครูเอ๋เอานิ้ว
เทียบกับกล้วยใช่ไหมคะไปค่ะนี่นักเรียนดู
กล้วยกูเห็นลมลบก่อนลบก่อนโทรเอา
นี้นะคะคุณทำแบบนี้
โอเคเข้าใจแล้วค่ะรูปนี้ก็คือรูปกล้วย
เล็บมือนาง 5
เอา
กล้วยเล็บมือนาง
นิ้วครูเอ๋กับกล้วยเท่าๆกันกล้วยจังลูก
บิ๊กๆค่ะขอรูปที่ 2 ก็คืออันนี้
คิดว่าเจ็บนะตอนแรก
คู๋ทำลูกกูเอกก็คิดไม่ยาก
ครูหญิงไม่เคยเห็นไม่รู้ก็คิดอะไรอะไรไม่
เข้าใจไม่เข้าใจผู้หญิงก็คิดว่ายากมากใช่
ไหมใช่ค่ะยากมากไม่รู้
โอเค
ผู้หญิงมีอีกสองรูปได้ค่ะผู้หญิงจะเอาแบบ
เปิดหรือแบบดู
เปิดค่ะ
รูปพระพุทธเล็กๆไม่เข้านะ
ฮะโอเคงั้นรูปต่อไปมีหนึ่งหนึ่งสองสามสี่
ห้าสีนะคะมี 5 สีมีห้าสีนะคะผู้หญิงอ่ะ
ค่ะสีอะไรคะสีแดง
2 สีอะไรคะสีเขียวอ่อน
3 สีอะไรคะสีฟ้า
สีอะไรคะสีเหลือง
ห้าสีอะไรคะสีส้มโอเคผู้หญิงจะเปิดสีอะไร
ก่อนคะสีเขียวอ่อนค่ะสีเขียวอ่อนเสียอะไร
ก็ได้นะที่ผู้หญิงอยากเปิดเบอร์ 2 ค่ะสี
เขียวอ่อนเปิดนะเปิดค่ะเปิดนะนักเรียน
ตื่นเต้นนะก็ถ้าคุยเปิดอันนี้แล้วตอบได้
เอาไปเลย 9 คะแนน 9 คะแนน
แล้วถ้าครูหญิงเนี่ยตอบเลยไม่เปิด 10
คะแนน
ครูเอกคะผู้หญิงไม่เห็นอะไรเลย
โอเคโอเคเปิดเปิด 1 เบอร์ 2 นะคะสีค่ะครู
เปิ้ลเปิดนะคะค่ะเปิดเปิดเปิดเปิด
กุ้ยเปิดผิด
โอเคคุยกลับไปกัน
ปิดมือสองหรอเบอร์ 2 ค่ะคุยเปิดได้ไหมอ่ะ
นั่นน่ะสิเปิดได้ไม่เปิดสองได้สิ
น่าจะได้ไหมโดย 2 เบอร์ 2 ไม่เป็นไรค่ะ
ครูเอ๋ครูหญิงเปลี่ยนใจค่ะเปิดสีฟ้าเบอร์
อ่าโอเคโอเคเปิดบริษัท 3 อ่ะเมื่อกี้อ่ะ
เบอร์ 3 ก่อนสีฟ้า
เป็นอันนี้หนูมีเนี่ยเหรอเอ้ารีวิวก่อน
แต่ที่ครูอยากให้ดูเนี่ยอ่าไม่ใช่วิว
อันนี้เป็นวิวใช่ไหมคะอ่าเปิดต่อไปเบอร์
อะไรคะ Birds  2 ค่ะเบอร์ 2 สีเขียวอ่อน
on เปิดนะคะค่ะ
อะไร
[เพลง]
อะไรอันนี้ก็เป็นเหมือน
บ้าน
เหมือนว่าบ้านขาโห
อะไรอะไรยังไม่ใช่
ครีมเปิดเบอร์ 4 ได้ไหมได้
เปิดว่าสีใช่ไหมคะเปิดเบอร์ 4 คุณป้า
อะไรสีเหลืองเปิดสีเหลืองเบอร์ชินเบอร์ 4
นะคะโอเคเป็น
[เพลง]
อะไรเบอร์ 4 เนี่ยอะไรเบอร์ 4 นี่เหมือน
เหมือนท่าเรือเลยนะเหมือนรอเรืออ๋อผู้
หญิงคิดว่าเป็นท่าเรือค่ะตอบว่าท่าเรือ
มั้ยหรือจะเปิดค่ะ
ท่าเรือ Green คิดว่ารูปนี้เป็นรูปค่า
เรือชัวร์หา
เบอร์ 4 นะอันนี้คือคำตอบท่าเรือณท่าเรือ
ตัวเปลี่ยนใจไหมไม่เปลี่ยนใจโอเคงั้นเอ็ม
เปิดสีส้มเบอร์ 5 ให้ดูนะคะผู้หญิงตอบว่า
ท่าเรือ
ใช่หรือไม่ใช่
คะคุณผู้หญิงกี่คะแนนนะ
2  44 คะแนนหรือได้ 0 คะแนนใช่ไหมคะ 3
สีส้มนะแต่นั้นแป้ง
ผู้หญิงดีใจใช่มั้ยป้าเหลือ
คุณเห็นต้องเปิดสีแดงผ้า
เรื่องผ้าเรืองเปิดนะจ้า
แมวเรือเย้
คู่เอ๋ฉันนะ
พาเรือจะเป็นอะไรคะเรือค่ะเรือนะคะ
เรืออยู่ที่ไหนระยะอยู่ที่แม่นางน้ำอ่ะ
เพื่ออยู่ที่แม่น้ำนะคะอันนี้คือแม่น้ำ
อุ้ยหมี
อันนี้อันนี้อันนี้เป็นรีวิวขอโทษค่ะ
เอ้าอันนี้เรือนะคะแล้วก็อันนี้แม่น้ำ
เท่านั้นเจ้าพระยานะคะ
คุณผู้หญิงหมดเวลาหรือยังเนี่ยอีกอันนึง
ได้ไหมลูกนึงมันไม่ชัดได้ค่ะเก๋เกินหน่อย
นะผู้หญิงอันนี้เป็นดูเป็นดูอ่ะให้ดู
คุยใจดีรูปที่ 1 เขียวเขียวๆๆเขียวอะไรคะ
เวลาว่ายน้ำหรอห่วงยางฝนเอาไว้หนาวหวยที่
นี่ห่วงยาแล้วอ๋อเพราะรูปข้างบนเป็นเรือ
รูปนี้คู่หญิงคิดเขียวเขียวๆออกว่ายน้ำแก
ไม่ไม่ใช่ค่ะรูปที่มีสองค่ารูปที่ 2
ขอสีแดงๆดำๆครีลิควินดูแล้วรู้อะไรอะไรคะ
เลือดหมูเลือดหมูโอเคโอ้ใต้
จะตอบเลยไหมคะ
หรือดูอีก
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวอะไรนะก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ID ก๋วยเตี๋ยวใช่แล้วให้ดูอีกอันนี้อะไร
อันนี้เหมือนเหมือนเกี๊ยวทอดอันนี้คือ
เกี๊ยวทอด
นักเรียนของกินผู้หญิง
ได้เพราะว่ากูให้ดูรูปที่ 2 เนี่ยเลือด
หมูต้องเป็นก๋วยเตี๋ยวที่อยู่ไว้ก็เป็น
ซุป
พอมีเกี๊ยวทอดเนี่ยก๋วยเตี๋ยวเลยใช่ไหมคะ
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวค่ะอยากดูรูปกับไปไหมนี้ให้ดู
อีกหรอคะใจดีพระผู้หญิงตอบแล้วว่า
ก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวอะไร
เดี๋ยวอะไรเนี่ยมีเลือดหมู
มีเกี๊ยวแล้วก็มีปลาหมึกท้ายก๋วยเตี๋ยว
อะไรนะก๋วยเตี๋ยวทะเลเหรอคะ
เอ้ยก๋วยเตี๋ยวทะเลมีเลือดหมูหรอไม่มีเฮ
ใช่ทะเลอะไรทะเลขอดูน้ำซุปมีน้ำซุปใช่ไหม
คะใช่ค่ะสีชมพูค่ะ
เย็นตาโฟค่ะก๋วยเตี๋ยวเย็นตาโฟ
ปิ๊งป่องโอเค
เดี๋ยวเปิดให้ดูนะคะผู้หญิงค่ะ
เดี๋ยวจะเห็นไหมเนี่ยเห็นข้ากำลังเห็น
กำลังเห็นใช่ไหมกูเอกกำลังเปิด
เปิดอะไรเนี่ย
เขา
โว้เห็นหน้าเห็นนะเห็นค่ะค่ะมีอ๊อดสี
เขียวคือชามก๋วยเตี๋ยวเขียว
ที่ 1
แล้วก็โอ๊ย
กูโอเคนั้นแล้วเนาะเป็นก๋วยเตี๋ยวอะไรนะ
คะถูกผู้หญิงก๋วยเตี๋ยวเย็นตาโฟทะเลไทย
ค่ะก๋วยเตี๋ยวเย็นตาโฟทะเล
อร่อยไก่ปลาหมึกใส่พารานะคะใส่กุ้งน้อง
เป็นอย่างมากผู้หญิงเก่ง
อีกหนึ่ง
ของกินเก่งมากนะคะเรือไม่เข้าใจถ้าก็วัน
นี้นะคะเรียนก็ก็รู้จักนะคะรู้จักเปิดนะ
คะรู้จักสีสีฟ้าสีแดงรู้จักอ่ะอ่ะ
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวเย็นตาโฟ
รู้จักอันนี้อะไรนะคะครูหญิงเรือ
อันนี้รู้จักอะไรคะรวยเล็บมือนางกล้วย
เล็บมือนางอันนี้เล็บนะคะ
เล็บใช่ไหมคะอันนี้มือชนะกล้วยเล็บมือนาง
ค่ะแล้วก็
แล้วก็อะไรคะ
ช้างค่ะอ่านั่งนะคะเราโอเคก็หมดเวลาแล้ว
ใครค่ะปวดหัวไหมคะพี่หัวค่ะผู้หญิงมีหัว
ค่ะ
โกเอ๋ไม่ปวดหัวคนลล์เล่นสนุก
โอเคงั้นครูเอ๋กับผู้หญิงไปก่อนนะคะถ้า
แล้วเจอกันวีดีโอหน้านะฮะถ้านักสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
อย่าลืมกดไลค์กูแชร์กด Subscribe นะคะอ่ะ